we have to ask you to address these
reports that hit today that you are
expecting a baby boy not true or not no
because you look really tiny kitty look
at that tummy completely flat ya know
and believe me I'm on the pill that's
not happening no no no no I'm so done I
really am et spoke with the Real
Housewives of New Jersey star Wednesday
night in New York City at the release
party for her new book turning the
tables she gushed over being back on the
reality show that made her famous but
said her daughter's don't exactly feel
the same big go with it but it's really
not their thing I mean like see gia she
said she wants to be a criminal attorney
so I hope if anything out of this comes
out that she does become a common
criminal attorney and helps another mom
stay home with her their daughters that
would make me so happy Teresa's husband
Joe is set to serve his prison sentence
starting next month the reality star
said she's now focused on setting a good
example for her girls Alyssa I missing
I'm gonna be a single mom shortly so I
need to like I want to get businesses
going again I got four mouths to feed
and that's it I want to show my
daughter's what it's all about being a
businesswoman